David says this man Oliver Anthony he's
referring to already admitted to his
faults he used to be a drunk he used to
enjoy cocaine anything to numb him from
the drab of everyday life uh it's been
addressed in his songs he's admitted and
repented no one can get a gotcha
question because he recognized his own
faults and speaks openly about them this
man is a real man start taking notes
well exactly and when they start digging
through his past which I'm sure they've
already started doing
um yeah it's you know
he's already said well I've done this
I'm a changed man uh and and we we
actually have to allow that allow
Redemption allow people to change
as as people do
um
and and you know also like in general
the good thing is that nobody cares
about this sort of thing anymore
um the digging through the we we've seen
enough of the whole routine of digging
through someone's closet for skeletons
from the past and we've seen it so many
times and we just don't care anymore
when the media comes to us and says oh
uh
guess what this person said or did 15
years ago we say well no it's all right
we don't we don't care
oh he said and did some stuff years ago
that might be embarrassing for him now
okay
yeah who hasn't
good to know now piss off thanks so
when now and again I'm I'm not aware of
that I don't know Oliver Anthony I'm not
aware of of anything
um embarrassing from his past aside from
things as you point out that he's
already admitted to and talked about in
his own testimony I'm just
I know how the media operates and so I'm
sure they are already looking for a
reason to destroy this guy and so I mean
I'm sort of anticipating that although I
hope it doesn't happen
another comment says it's a good song
but I don't listen to music with
profanities I know that Oliver is new to
Faith and I pray he will be inspired to
make songs in the future that truly
honor God Matt I know you say that the
language isn't a problem but would you
let your kids speak that way uh speak
the way he does in the song
yeah I've been arguing about this today
I mean look first of all the s word is
not a profanity I don't mean to be
pedantic here but the s word
and I hate that I even have to call it
the s word because it'll be bleeped out
which I don't even think the daily wire
should bleep out it's it's not a it's a
dumb thing to believe about it just is
but
um
it's not a profanity because the
profanity is profane
and to be profane is to disrespect or
Sully something that is sacred that is
that is a profanity
okay
um
So when you say BS you're not profaning
cow manure
the the thing that the s word is
referring to is not a sacred thing so
the word is not profane it may be crass
but there's nothing intrinsically
immoral about the language
um and that's how people Express
frustration oftentimes you know and it's
real it's raw and and and frankly I
don't think it would have sounded
as powerful if you know instead of I've
been selling my soul working all day
overtime hours for pay instead
of that if it was I've been selling my
soul working all day uh overtime hours
for inadequate pay
or whatever that language would not be
as powerful it just it wouldn't sound as
good it wouldn't be It wouldn't connect
with people as much I think the language
he chose again is real and it sounds
like how people actually talk and that's
part of what gives it its power what I
let my kids use that language absolutely
not that doesn't make it profane either
there are lots of words that I don't let
my kids say you know like shut up uh
idiot stupid I mean I don't let my kids
say any of that stuff
and um that doesn't make it a profanity
it's just I don't let my kids talk that
way uh I mean
I wouldn't let my kids talk about
selling their souls in a metaphorical
way if my six-year-old came down from
from uh cleaning his room and said I'm
tired of selling my soul Dad working all
day for this terrible allowance
if he said that to me he'd be in trouble
like five times over
but that doesn't mean that adults can't
use that language as many of you know
we've been giving our dog rough greens
for a while now and he loves it while
our dog still might be a freeloader at
least he's not a lazy freeloader he's
happier healthier and has more energy
naturopathic Dr Dennis black the founder
of rough grains is focused on improving
the health of every dog in America
little did I know before I got rough
grains that dog food is dead food
everybody knows that nutrition is not
brown it's green well let rough greens
boost your dog's food back to life rough
grains is a supplement that contains all
the necessary vitamins minerals
probiotics Mega oils digestive enzymes
and antioxidants so your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food you just sprinkle rough Greens on
their food every day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough grains
it supports healthy joints improves bad
breath Boost energy levels and so much
more we are what we eat and that goes
for our dogs too naturopathic Dr Dennis
black is so confident rough grains will
improve your dog's health he's offering
my listeners a free jump start trial bag
so your dog can try out that's a free
jumpstart trial bag that can be found
and at your door in just a few business
days go to freerofgreens.com math or
call 844 rough 700 that's free Ruff
greens.com Matt or call 844 rough 700
today
and this is actually important because
if you're
if you're saying that when an artist
puts his Lamentations and frustrations
to words
that he must only use words that we
would allow a six-year-old to say
then you really have put some very
unnecessary uh and suffocating
limitations on his artistic expression
and you're also demanding that we take
something raw and real and we sanitize
it
and I just don't agree with that
so look if you take this hard line
position on on cuss words on what you
would call I think inaccurately
profanities
um
it's not a big deal I can respect that I
mean congratulations you found one area
where you are to the right of me where
you're where you're more conservative
than me arguably uh so that's the one
it's the only time you can you can sort
of like out angle me on the on the way
you can take a better angle and get to
the
get to the right quicker than I can
um
so congratulations on that and if you if
if that's your position then it's not a
big deal it's not worth really getting
into a big argument about but
uh I I also just think that it's wrong
like I think that there's there's a time
and a place for certain words that we
wouldn't allow kids to say and uh when
it comes to an adult singing about his
Sorrows when it comes to Art you know
sometimes that sort of stuff comes out
and I think we have to uh allow for that
and um
to me it is a silly thing to complain
about it just is all right
let's see
uh Trent says this whole Oliver Anthony
thing seems astroturfed and fake in my
opinion
the song was produced by a right-wing
influencer named Jason Howerton look it
up
km says Matt I like Oliver Anthony's
voice and he seems like a nice guy but
his lyrics you have to admit are
simplistic and politically all over the
place the stuff about taxes and Welfare
is pure establishment Republican stuff
okay uh and please stop this too because
I've seen a lot of this both of these
kinds of comments first Oliver Anthony
was not astroturfed Jason Howerton
offered to pay to produce his his album
in the future like he didn't produce the
song that made him go viral he's saying
if you want to make an album in the
future I'll pay to produce it uh how did
it go viral well
somebody posted it on Twitter and a few
big accounts saw it myself included and
we liked it and so we reposted it and a
bunch of other people liked it and so
they reposted it and that's how it
started you know uh that's not fake it's
not astro turf not everything is a
dastardly plot for God's sake
and if you see a guy singing a folk song
in the woods on an obscure YouTube
channel and you think man there must be
a lot of money and a huge conspiracy
behind this then I don't know what to
say
um you're dealing with the terminal
brain rot in that case and I really
don't know what else to tell you
um and as for the lyrics they aren't
simplistic they're simple there's a
difference
they're simple lyrics that communicate
raw emotion and real human suffering
that others can relate to this is It's
folk music in other words right that's
what folk music does that's that's the
art from form so so what do you want
do you want something that like sounds
like it was made by a guy who went to
the the Juilliard school or something
that's not what this is this is good
old-fashioned folk music Americana Roots
country whatever you want to call it
whatever genre you want to call it and
and any and Anthony is not a political
pundit okay and I see this on the right
there's been some of this going on of
like dissecting
the National Review had an article about
it and they were dissecting the politics
of it just just stop okay
relax
so this this is when people on the right
just start acting like a bunch of dorks
honestly
um well let's look at the politics and
according to this he's the this he's
this is where he lies on the political
spectrum of
he's
offering Lamentations that are familiar
to normal people uh some of it might
qualify as populist some of it might
fall outside that label as it's
traditionally understood who cares
is that what we what we do with music
now is that what we do with art
try to figure out what ideological label
to put on it and then we wonder why
there's not enough art on the right
because the moments anyone that is you
know not on the left puts out a piece of
art we have to start
tearing it to shreds
politically analyzing every last
syllable
coming up with all these conspiracy
theories or where did this guy come from
there's something going on here there's
someone behind this like just shut up
if this is how you respond to stuff then
don't complain when we don't have art
and entertainment on the right because
you are the reason why you make it
impossible
you just can't accept anything you can't
accept you just can't take anything and
say well you know that's a powerful
moment this is good it's someone you
just you can't you you you're incapable
of it
and there's there's some conservatives
like that it drives me crazy okay
so give it a rest
and I will too for the time being
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
Walsh show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcasts